tweet from Mike
Ben he says watch this incredible moment
that a watch the incredible moment that
a rep from the Pentagon psychological
operation's research firm pitched NATO's
military scup Center on turning Taylor
Swift into an asset for the Western
military Alliance to stop disinformation
on the internet excuse me well let me
play first the beginning so the first
one that's the most famous um and the
most um most common is working with
famous people um or influencers to share
uh information a particular message okay
now I'm going to pause real quick the
image being displayed at saon that's a
Cy con it says identification and
segmentation in the identification era
it shows Taylor Swift and it says goal
identify key actors to train and spread
desire me desired messaging example
encourage opinion leaders to share
counter IO content risk opinion leaders
may not want to share content or may
accidentally share misleading content
let's play more so Taylor Swift in here
because are you kidding
me so yes Mike is clearly uh enjoying
that they've included Taylor Swift in
here but I must
stress many people have been accusing
Taylor Swift of being a scop or being in
on psychological operations to some
degree this is an example being given
from what I can see here in this clip
the woman did not say we literally are
working with Taylor Swift she says I use
Taylor Swift as an example
that being said what people need to
understand about uh the potential for
psychological operations and high level
influence in on it it's that you know uh
who was it I think I was talking to to
Sheamus about this earlier we were
talking about who's possibly a Fed in
media yeah we're talking about Ray EPS
we have our we have a little um
corkboard with Tim takes Polaroids of
people when they do the podcast and we
put them on the cork a bunch of yarn red
string we tie around the thumb and we're
trying to figure it out so we actually
we weeded a couple out I think but uh we
were talking about who may actually be
feds mhm let me let me inform all of you
guys there are no feds you know there
there are feds there are federal
informants but the idea that people
working in media are secretly Federal
informance is just absolutely not the
case the idea that Taylor Swift is a
Handler I would say is absolutely not
the case but I will tell you what is
very likely the case I explained this a
long time ago and I'll explain it to you
all again you can go on Google ads and
choose to run advertisements of any sort
on any channel you want so let's say you
want a particular kind of political
content to be successful if the CIA or
the FBI wanted certain messaging to be
dominant in this country all they would
have to do is create a proxy company go
onto Google ads buy ads at at high rates
on an individual's Channel let's say
they like Freedom Tunes sh Channel and
they say his content he's producing is
well well let's put it this way let's
let's let's let's accuse timcast let's
go with timcast we are
anti-establishment but we're not super
far right or anything like that we're
fairly moderate on the political
positions but we're very
anti-establishment notice he he had to
switch to timcast to make that point
he's like freedom freedom Tunes is just
too far out there but so the the
argument would be this if the federal
government liked that for instance after
Donald Trump was defeated by Joe Biden
the 2020 election and I don't mean
fairly I'm quite I'm literally saying
Biden is in the White House they the
feds then go you know look we got a
bunch of conservatives over here saying
Trump won then we got someone like Tim P
who almost agrees with them on all these
other issues so he's got a big portion
of the audience but he is saying Joe
Biden won what do they do nobody emails
me nobody comes here knocks on the door
and says Mr pool we'd like to pay you to
say these things for us what they do is
they target people who they think have
the message message they like by ads in
like indiscriminately and just
discreetly on Google and what I mean is
they'll just indiscriminately as in
they'll pull up a big thing of people
and just throw money at them and they
don't care what you say they don't ask
you to say things they just funnel money
secretly through an automated
programmatic system so when people argue
that Taylor Swift is a scop they don't
need to send someone to ask you to do it
what what happens is Taylor Swift makes
music people like it Taylor Swift then
says I'm voting for Biden and KLA Harris
they say you know we really like that
message let's uh let's use one of our
proxy companies to sponsor her next tour
and give her a million dollars that
million dollars will go towards her
expanding her
business that's the game yeah that's how
they run scops yeah we were talking
about this also you got to remember like
it's not as if you have to pay people to
believe things that are wrong every time
someone says something that another
person disagrees with they'll go like
you're a grifter you're only saying that
cuz it's a financial incentive as if no
one has ever been incorrect about
anything because they just came to the
wrong conclusion on their own it's like
sometimes people just believe things
that are wrong in fact it's crazy most
of the time people believe things that
are wrong right and you don't have to
believe that the federal government is
paying somebody the reality is we live
in a system where people are not
encouraged to choose virtue when you're
not encouraged to choose virtue you're
going to take the path of least
resistance as often as possible and that
means falling in line with opinions that
are more popular because it's difficult
to argue for unpopular opinions that's
all it is you don't have to fund anybody
you don't have to run any kind of like
Special Operation to get pop artist like
come on why does someone become just
think about it why does someone become a
pop artist why does someone become a
famous actor because they want to be
liked so as long as the culture says
being liked means having these opinions
then they're going to have those
opinions you don't have to Blackmail
them you don't have to give them money I
I I I I partly disagree a lot of people
who get famous end up not liking being
famous and and they quit they try to
hide a lot of people who get famous
enjoy being famous it's not absolute so
when I look at someone like Taylor Swift
I don't know so much that when she was a
little kid she she said I wish I was
famous other than she made music the
music got popular now she's famous there
are certainly people who want nothing
but to be famous and what what do you
see they make up fake garbage on social
media for clicks and likes and that is a
lot of people but even even when it's
not a Pursuit Of Fame and I'm not saying
that there are no famous artists who
just believe in their craft but any kind
of perform performance art is going to
disproportionately attract people who
are attention seeking and want large
crowds to like
them yeah it's like it doesn't have to
be a formal conspiracy anyway people are
just doing what they want to do they're
doing what's best for them you know
there's a much easier SS conspiracy that
we all already know about and I will
stress it again the feds don't need to
go to any individual Creator and offer
them money or recruit them and they're
secretly CIA it's actually much easier
they send a national security letter to
Facebook and they say we want your
algorithm to prop up this kind of
content yeah that's it well and I think
this and ban this kind of content this
is where thing actually I mean this is
part of where things actually start to
get really scary I remember there was
something um my dad said to me when I
was in high school asked him like do you
believe in any conspiracy theories and
he said no I like there the government
doesn't need to cover anything up
because the media will just call you
racist or sexist or homophobic or evil
if you point out things that are
actually happening uh and and try to
destroy you that way but nowadays that's
not working like it used to so they
actually do have to interfere in ways
that they didn't before because they
don't control information as tightly as
they used to which is why we saw uh as
Tim alluded to the White House
communicating with Facebook about what
kind of information should be allowed on
that platform
yeah yeah I mean it's this is not
something that that uh um that that
really should be comes any kind of
surprise we've talked about it you know
here all time you're saying that Taylor
Swift is working for
this I don't know that I don't think
that I don't think that
anyone or I don't think there are
actually assets like that I think that
the the incentive structures that are
built up uh don't require that and and
and it's the it's it's the same thing
with when it comes to like the Deep
state right like you don't all the Deep
state is is your average people that are
bureaucrats that don't change when the
administration po the the policy but how
cool would it be Taylor Swift was like
at January 6th telling people to R she's
down there going
like she's no no no I say how cool would
it be if like you know 30 34 years ago
two people are recruited by the CIA to
have a child which would go on to become
a pop star to influence and control the
minds of the youth and then you've got
like seven-year-old Taylor Swift
learning like you know I don't know
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and like Krav Maga
and then they're like next up will be
your piano training and they like teach
her to sing that's the whole thing was
one big military site up to control the
world's population ISAC getting into the
uh Donald Trump was a uh Soviet asset
territory I just like Trump trump was a
Soviet attempt to to raise someone but
they kind of screwed it up because they
had like a lack of you know proper
resources and then Trump went rogue and
became like a world leader in the other
direction I just I I like the idea that
Taylor Swift is like a Fed the sense
that people usually call attractive
women online feds like she's like in
people's DMS telling them to commit gun
crimes and stuff she's like what if you
drilled another hole there are no there
are no women online remember that
they're all feds Every Woman online if a
woman appears even remotely attractive
on the internet she is a fed that's
factually true that is true that's the
thing that's true about mm RPGs right
you'll see like a female character it's
just a guy playing a female character
right it's like women are playing Candy
Crush you know what I mean yeah that's
true no that's a fact that's actually
overwhelmingly play I love these reports
where they're like women now make up 51%
of Gamers and it's like yeah but you
mean like Candy Crush and Angry Birds
they do they do they do usually that's
hilarious like how many women are
playing balers Gate 3 like a small
percentage you know what I mean and you
know what women get so mad and I'm
saying this is a non-gamer okay but
women get so mad at guys for playing
video games you don't hear guys out here
knocking Candy Crush going like I hate
that my girlfriend plays Candy Crush but
the girls are like why is he always
playing Call of Duty it's like look at
the apps on your own iPhone okay look at
the games you're playing like every guy
know those aren't the games they play
they play games with your head remember
remember when uh it was fresh and fit
they said women don't have hobbies yeah
it's true and they were like why would
he say that but it's like it's because
from a male perspective they don't like
women obviously have hobbies but from a
male perspective they don't so like if I
go to a skate park there's going to be
one woman for every 15 or 20 guys if I
go to the poker room there's going to be
one woman for every 15 or 20 guys when
you when you go to these kinds of things
that guys normally do you you don't see
that many women MH however I don't know
is like getting your hair done in like
fashion a hobby some people argue it is
and so it's like what do women enjoy
doing it's just not the same as what
guys enjoy doing so guys don't see women
around all the time well also so this is
this is my theory and I think this is
actually validated by a lot of the
metrics we have like AQ for example but
I think it applies uh across a wide span
of human activities where men either
tend to be like really good at things or
really bad at things whereas women tend
to be more average so again we see this
with IQ men and women have the same
average IQ but men are more likely to be
smart or dumb whereas women are more
likely to actually just be greater male
variability hypothesis exactly and so I
think that's why you see men in a lot
more of these Hobbies uh I think men are
just more likely to become obsessive
over something and get really into it
whereas women are more likely to be
normal yeah yeah to generalize no it's
true that's that's one of the cool
things about being a man is like there
is this um proclivity to just find
something you're really interesting in
and obsess over it and I I think that
women have that to a degree for sure but
it's it manifests very differently
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net